that wasn't so nice I feel sad you can't
make Jewish brothers be mean to each
other hi my name is Marcy Basha I'm
Naomi grower
hi I'm Helene hi I'm Jennifer Daniels my
name is Shannon Sarna and I'm so happy
to be here every holiday we have except
for Thanksgiving there must be brisket
it's a crowd-pleaser and everybody loves
it everybody expects it and they bring
containers to take stuff home so what
makes the perfect brisket
okay well definitely you have to have
love when you're thinking about your
family and the holiday and your cooking
all of that is going into your cooking
so that's number one you gotta like sear
the [ __ ] out of it till it's like super
caramelized on both sides and you like
add all your aromatics carrots onions
celery people do with fear people do
with tomatoes people do it with soy
sauce then it goes in the oven for a
good 3 plus hours watch good movie you
know do some laundry and just continuing
on and adding more and more love to it
Jewish food is all super ugly brown
mushy
it's terrible to photograph and it looks
kind of gross but the taste is just
amazing I'm gonna be a hundred percent
honest when I evaluate each brisket I
think all these Jewish moms can take it
okay bring it I've tried many Persky
recipes but I'm very excited about this
one there was dredging there was searing
simmering and boiling and waiting and
adding more ingredients so this was a
lot of work but in the end we were like
oh my god it's so good oh this one looks
it's cut very thick not my thing
the chunky veggies but it smells pretty
good I'm gonna try
it's alright it's good not great but
it's definitely you know edible I I
think maybe it could use a little more
flavor I don't like carrots cut its cut
a little too thick for my liking I think
I could use a little bit more sauce or
gravy however you want to call it this
one's really good it's tender but it's
not overly sweet I think this one is
really excellent this one's pretty good
she clearly loves her family a lot no we
all love our families come on guys I
think I'm going with a sex here I would
serve this to my family if I had to I
know they would prefer mine over this of
course but one to ten I would give this
a six I think I would give this one like
I like a 9.5 that's really good
I'd give her an 8 just because I got to
leave room for me I'd like to say that
it is a family recipe handed down from
my mom my children's grandma and they
are great grandma Laura
however I've definitely tweaked it quite
a bit over the years my secret
ingredient is an entire bottle of red
wine - maybe a few sips ok let's see
what we have here ok this one looks
really really nice
can I request when you do mine that you
put a nice piece out like this this
looks pretty mindless I'm gonna make a
plate for you I just I can't I can't
it looks like it was cooked well looks
like it has some fat on it so that's
always good I don't know a little dry
looking but I guess we'll have to taste
it to see this is good I think it's
really good but just to bring it up to
that great level I would just add a
little bit more flavor to it
that's alright not my favorite I don't
love that I see the baby carrots in here
like this which are kind of the ones
that you get in the bag the baby carrots
say like it was easy to throw the throw
carrots and I didn't have to peel
anything so maybe she was rushed for
time or she doesn't like to peel or shed
her nails done maybe but I think
everything is really good it looks like
just like the perfect homemade holiday
brisket I think I'd give it a 6 I would
give this a seven I would rate this and
eat I would serve this to my kids I
don't know what she did to this but
doesn't taste like Jewish brisket at all
I think there's like peppers in this
it's weird
mmm no I don't like this one at all I
would not serve this one to my family
not even to my boss enemies I wouldn't
serve this one okay to give it a minus
one I make the best brisket of everybody
that's what everybody tells me
especially my husband and my children my
mom always made it my grandmother always
made it my aunt's always made it now I'm
making it alright so we've got a Dicer
she dices her carrots this smells really
good and it looks very tomatoey savory
let's give it a try this one has a nice
flavor I like this the sauce is really
good but it's a little bit tough this
one's a little sweeter than my likings
um I don't enjoy continuing with this
one I think it's somebody who probably
learned it from their mom and just like
did exactly how their they were kind of
like taught to do it I would give it a 5
I think they've given an 8 I would make
this if someone said I would try this
recipe it was really good I try and I
don't know if it would replace my family
recipe but I think I would I would try
it and I think my family would like it I
would give this a seven what give it a
fair five now I just have to only hope
that I don't have a bump into any the
other women like in a shop right or
somewhere
I don't know if I would never see like
my brisket is the best but I'm proud of
my brisket so over the years its kind of
developed between a hybrid of Uncle
David Simkins brisket and my husband who
is also a really good cook I like to add
beer soda homemade stock and a lot of
red wine I like to serve it for parties
I'm shredded with little mini homemade
holler oles and that's one of everyone's
favorite this looks like brisket but you
know briskets not a pretty food well
it's cutting really nicely it's really
tender
mmm too much fat the flavor isn't
terrible but the cut of meat I can't get
past it probably would have worked
better as a shredded barbecue not as a
whole slice like that I like to serve it
Chouard too fatty for me it's a little
bit fatty and that is a problem when
your brisket tastes better than it looks
let me just taste it again let me see if
I had to rate it I think I'd give it a 5
or sorry
I'll give it a 5 it's good different but
it's good
[Music]
so this is my brisket that's a recipe
that sort of evolved over years lots of
family feedback and I guess I can't give
all of the secrets but there's coca-cola
in here ah it's a family favorite for
holidays and my kids kind of think that
it's best brisket out there okay
smells really good it presents nicely
it's saathi there are no carrots there
are no onions so I'm a little suspicious
gonna try happens to be good this means
this one's really good very similar to
mine really sweet it's a little spicy
maybe it needed to cook like a smidge
longer but overall I really like it she
does a nice job she did a very nice job
this is good it feels like maybe there's
some maybe some brown sugar in there a
little bit more sweet probably more of
my liking then as I told you my pizza
bagels likings are but it's not bad I
would definitely serve this to my family
Oh give it an 8 I would give it an
annoying give it a 7 I'll give us a 9
I want
[Music]
can I give you a hug my family said if I
didn't win it had to be ripped
[Music]